[Music]
sorry
okay that's pretty good
you may know Michael
is an amazing composer
but he also is a very talented director
werewolf by night
I've been wanting to make since I was
making movies when I was a kid hopefully
it goes as smoothly as those old Super 8
movies
um he's going to be directing for Marvel
Michael's wanted to do this since he was
a kid
directing this movie it's really just an
extension of what I've always done
to be able to make a Marvel monster
movie I'm so lucky
it's my life right now
Marvel Studios director By Night a
behind the scenes look at werewolf By
Night
MCU Marvel Cinematic Universe oh
okay now streaming only on Disney Plus